[موسيقى]
هذه القريه سميت باسم املحها نسبه للملح
اللي موجود في المنطقه كي جاو الجدود من
بكري نلقاوها بداو يخدمو فيها تخرجوا
الملاح
[موسيقى]
الملح نعيط
حاره مختار جزائر
[موسيقى]
لا عدناك عشرين سنه ولا 25 حتى 30 سنه من
اللور نلقاو الناس وكل خدام يعيشوا بالملح
هذا
[موسيقى]
في هذه المنطقه في فصل الصيف فقط لازم
تكون الحراره عامل المناخره مهم جدا
لاستخراج الملح
[موسيقى]
55 سنه قريه تشكيب بن بلديه فرعون بجايه
هذه المهنه منذ سن 15 سنه في بدايه الصيف
نخزنوا الماء في المخازن التعالمياه
نجيبوهم المنبع الاساسيه نسموه العينصر كي
نجمعو الماء في المخازن هادو باش يتنقى
[موسيقى]
كان بداو عمليه جمع الملح نعمره اسطوح
كيتبخر الماء يخرج لنا الملح نجمعوه ومن
بعد كي نجمعو الملحه هذا من الاسطر هادو
واحد المكان نعيطوا له اصوات بالقبايليه
وين يتجفف الملح يروحوا الماء ومن بعد
يكون نعمروه ويكون صالح للبيع والماكله
[موسيقى]
عندنا الملح الاول يديوها للجزارين يديروه
الجلود يبعثوا
للاكل ولكل المستعملات في المنازل
[موسيقى]
مهرجان ملح هذه فكره حبينا يكون عندنا
انوبيرج باش تولي منطقه سياحيه جبليه
الملح تاعنا ويكون معروف يخرج
الولايات الاخرين يعرفو هذا
[موسيقى]
جايين اناس
ومن كل مناطق تاع الجزائر ايشوفوها
[موسيقى]
منهج روش بارسكو كاين كلش كاين الماء كاين
الاراضي الفلاحيه كاين تيملاحين يخدموا
بها بكري
[موسيقى]